mayor of london is with us lots to talk
about i just wondered if you wanted to
comment on that to start with the kurt
zuma kicking his cat i don't know if you
saw the video it's despicable i think a
number of things need to happen urgently
i think the rspca and the police need to
work together to prosecute this player
i'm disappointed in david moyes and west
ham actually
i i know how important three points i
support a club as well but i think they
should have shown leadership
and dropped him uh last night and i
worry when young people see
paramedic footballers getting away with
bad behavior or prime ministers or
anybody else that thinks it's okay and
you can be successful that's why it's
really important for leaders and role
models and whether you're a footballer
or the mayor or you know journalists
we're role models and we should lead by
example
um
talking about mentor mentoring actually
that's a program that you want to
introduce in london well i benefited as
a young boy from mentors my teachers
were great my big brothers uh youth
workers one of the things we're trying
to do in addition to
you know and violence by supporting the
police give young people alternatives to
joining the criminal gang
to get involved in criminality uh to for
them to have the potential fulfilled by
giving them a help in hand so we're
doing one of two things one is to
every young person have access to good
quality facilities but secondly every
young person in need to have access to a
dedicated mentor who can nurture support
and guide them when they're at that
crossroads where they could make the
wrong choice and the idea is for this
helping hand to particularly help those
young learners who've been excluded from
school who may be at risk of uh you know
being exploited maybe living in poverty
may have seen domestic violence at home
uh you know maybe in care so they've got
a mentor to help them have their
potential for how will that work how
will they access that so
for those uh young londoners in pupil
referral units we'll have people going
into the pius tell them they've already
been excluded from school
we'll have uh
great partnership with councils with
youth workers with those in the private
sector we're particularly working with
those employees in steam jobs you know
science
tech engineering arts manufacturing so
they will be working with us as well
because you and i i'm sure both
benefited from having people we can talk
to people who can guide us and too many
young londoners don't and that's why
we've set up this scheme today
and when does it start it starts today
it starts today and if people want to
know more about it not necessarily for
themselves but for um it gives me an
excuse to plug my twitter account and
also the city hall uh website all deals
will be given out uh today we're
particularly focusing on those people
who we think are in need uh many people
have the advantage of having vulnerables
anyway and mentors our focus is those in
need and with this helping hand can have
their potential fulfilled just while
we're talking about um tweets i've just
been seeing jillian keegan has um has
tweeted overnight she tested positive
um and still was in a meeting and
decided not to leave because she was
speaking um or listening to three
fathers who'd lost their daughters to
suicide difficult position for her to be
in should she have left or not
uh i've just seen this now well if it
was me
i'd have let people listen i just i've
just tested uh uh positive because you
may be shielding you may have immunity
issue uh you should be informed of this
if you've had your boosters and your
vaccines you may decide to stay i would
have kept it silent
and then made an informed choice uh as
and then unfortunately i've not tested
positive yet my experience though
is uh you know the consequences of
passing this on
uh to somebody who may be immunity
suppressed who may have issues relation
to
loved ones at home who are elderly means
you could inadvertently they could pass
it on to somebody else's transmission
this the omicron is very transmissible
yeah uh and that's why i i'd always earn
this out of caution uh and let people
know and then exit soon as i can so she
should have left then
i don't know the facts of this case uh
uh i will almost certainly have left
um you also tweeted didn't you earlier
on in the week when we saw that
ridiculous nonsense um just outside the
palace of westminster across the road
there where uh kyo starmer and uh the
shadow foreign secretary were trying to
leave and they were literally in fact
that's your tweet um
are you criticizing boris johnson there
yeah can i still do this this point head
on uh okay it's a really important point
i know you've been challenging uh
politicians and leaders over the last
few days about this i think what boris
johnson sought to do at the dispatch box
uh a couple weeks ago is
at least two things
one is to distract us from talking about
um
the law being broken by him and others
potentially in relation to bring your
own boos
and secondly amplifying conspiracy
theories which will snowball and which
will become a talking point in relation
to the leader of the next general
election
there is no doubt that these
anti-vaxxers
heard what johnson said which and it
normalized some of the views on the
periphery and you'll have heard some of
the abuse
was basically paraphrasing and quoting
what our prime minister had uh said and
what you do often is when you do this
you those views on the periphery become
normalized and mainstream which gives
people sucker to behave in this way
what should the met
do about stuff like this i mean it's
been going on for ages now if it's not
these two then it's somebody else you
know they've harassed journalists
they've harassed all sorts of people and
they just seem to be able to do it
and nothing happens look we're on a
slippery slope here on the one hand i
want you and me to be able to
go around a bit go out of business mix
and mingle
with
ordinary londoners ordering people and
not have to worry about our security the
reality though is
is for good reasons there's security
coming into here
you know people like me have security
protection
because there have been too many
examples of politicians journalists uh
being threatened sometimes unfortunately
having their lives lost and that's why
this is a slippery slope why because i i
don't live in a society where you and i
are cut off
from ordinary people so on the one hand
the police have a really important job
to keep us safe
on the other hand
protest is perfectly permissible i
encourage protests i encourage dissent i
encourage me being challenged you know
by you and by others but it's got to be
done within the boundaries of the law
and in a peaceful way these people these
anti-vaxxers that they've disrupted
beings i've held they've often been a
hateful and incited hate and be quite
aggressive towards
me
if we're not careful
you know the next generation of joe
cox's kirsten armors to david emissions
will say you know what i don't want to
be a politician because
it's too risky or dangerous and their
moms and dads will say you shouldn't go
into politics because you know life's
too short last time you're on the
program actually um we were talking
about the party gate allegations and you
said that it was a slam dunk but boris
johnson is still in downing street so
what's going on
well i suspect what he's doing is trying
to hang on for dear life
you know he's kicked the can down the
road saying he's waiting for the sue
gray report and the met police uh uh
report uh i've got to be frank i i i
condors regularly the labour party
benefits from borrowers johnson still
being the leader of the tory party the
prime minister our country suffers
though and that's why i think it's
really important for
uh conservatives
who have the power to remove him to
think do i want to be like the
republicans in america who failed to get
rid of trump
or do i want to be like the proud tory
that i am who understands the importance
of law and order and sounds important
high standards and gets rid of this guy
and listen i've got to be honest
for selfish reasons right as a labour
politician as a labour member i want
this guy to stay because he's a vote
winner for us but it just does down uh
this high standards that we hold in
relation to a prime minister
being investigated by the police
breaking the law
breaking rules that many many people
were following you know i attended
a a funeral of my father-in-law uh
during pandemic we couldn't do the stuff
we'd like to do limited numbers of
people
uh one of my neighbors lost his life
from cowed i couldn't attend his funeral
because i followed the rules and there
are thousands and thousands of families
across our country who did the right
thing
because the prime minister uh changed
the law passed these rules and
unreasonably
uh they are looking at the hypocrisy of
the prime minister and hoping he does
the right thing and if he doesn't hoping
that the party he belongs to and those
that work for him do the right thing and
get rid of him the met and more
precisely um christopher dick was
criticized for the way that the
investigation into what happened in
downing street was carried out you
defended her at the time but over the
last few days you've now said that she's
on notice what does that actually mean
well let me distinguish uh the
allegations arranged to dentistry are
you know
still an operational matter it's not
right for me to comment on operational
matters i'm a politician
with some skin in the game
how would we feel if i as a lady
politician was influencing that police
service to investigate a tory prime
minister and that's why i'm quite clear
i don't get involved in operational
matters in the likes of live
investigations in relation to the
commissioner being put unnoticed what i
mean by that
is i read the report from the
independent office for police conduct
ipc
which set out in black and white some of
the language used by serving police
officers 14 14
police officers that was racist sexist
misogynistic anti-semitic islamophobic
and some
none of the 14 are still
serving
i was shocked uh disgusted and angry
when i read that report
and so
when i spoke to the commissioner i
called her in
i made clear
at least two things one
you need to show me as the police and
crime commissioner as the mayor of this
city what your plans are
to root out
uh officers who are racist sexist
misogynistic and so forth
two
what are your plans to win back the
transfer confidence of those londoners
who i'm afraid had their confidence
knocked and shattered by the paver
police service and what should you say
well i'll be seeing her again uh in the
next few days and weeks for the
commissioner
to have the opportunity to come back to
the questions i've asked and let's wait
and see what she says and if you're not
satisfied well one of the things i've
got to do as the mayor of london
is to ensure those who work for me have
the same high standards that i expect of
myself if it's the case that anybody who
works for me uh can't deliver on the
really important issue of ensuring
londoners have trusted confidence in
them and those they lead uh then i won't
be staying silent about that and i'll
take action and what might that look
like well let's wait and see i mean it's
not the first time there was i mean
we're thinking particularly about sarah
average um
she stood by her officers and their
behavior uh on on that occasion but
there was much criticism for that
absolutely there's a list
i won't go through the list but you know
there's a list of reasons why people
feel that they're not very happy with
christmas
one thing that's that's uh uh that's
that's
written by the iopc that's that's really
important is the iopc make the point
this these examples in china cross
aren't isolated or historic and it's
really important why do i say that
because we are pleased by consent we
rely upon people coming forward to
report a crime we rely on people coming
forward to be when they've been a
witness to crime relying people to come
forward and join our police service if
it's the case that members of the public
haven't got confidence in our police
service by the way we've got some
brilliant police officers who are
incredibly brave and we should be really
grateful absolutely we've got these fine
offices but if it's the case that people
can't do that
because they've not got trust confidence
in the culture in our police service
there are issues of systemic bad
behavior that's a problem for all of us
and that's why it's so important and so
profound so let's wait and see what the
commissioner does in relation to what
i've said to her
i've been elected by londoners to be
their police and crime commissioner and
that includes holding the commissioner
to account yeah but let's cut to the
chase if you don't get the right answers
and she's been on notice not just for
this but for many other occasions as i
illustrated one or two of them then it
would you you would not hesitate in
saying it's time for you to go
yeah it's very important for londoners
to know that if anybody who works for me
isn't up to the standard as long as i
expect i expect them to go
and when will you uh expect to hear back
from her uh we're talking about days and
weeks
and when you spoke to her the other day
what was it a testy meeting how did it
yeah i'm not going to full details and
stuff but i think it is in the public
interest for for me to share with you
yeah it was it was a
90-minute plus meeting
and the two things that are of public
interest
is me being quite clear in relation to
uh the commissioner
needs to come back to me and show me
uh that she has a clear plan an
immediate plan to root out offices like
this
cultures that leads to this sort of
stuff and secondly
an immediate plan to win by the trust of
confidence
final thought something else that is
troubling a lot of londoners at the
moment is the ridiculous amount of money
that was spent on the vanity project
that is the mound at marble arch six
million quid to put it up goodness knows
how much it's costing to take it down
what a waste of money that was uh well i
i agree um and uh westminster council um
you know uh need to be held to count to
voters in westminster there are council
issues coming up in may and i'd suspect
those people i know i paid my council
tax to them yeah well i i can suspect
you'll be voting for them this may
hopefully
i i don't vote i have to pray at that
point then i can be um level-headed and
and even-handed with politicians of all
sides i'd encourage everyone to vote
labour as a rule of course you would of
course you would and and perhaps you'll
be uh
i don't know in number 10 before we know
it who knows
you didn't say no there well i think i
think you know i would care to be number
10 as soon as possible you you've got a
good competitor i meant you no no i mean
listening here's the leader of our party
and i support him fully but you've got
to compare and contrast between a man of
dignity somebody of high standards a
public servant his entire life a serious
person honest straight decent and boris
johnson it's a no-brainer yeah sadly
we're out of time it's always great to
talk to you we'll have to try and get
you on we're going to ask the education
secretary on thursday and we've got a
bit longer with him maybe can i just say
that nadeem sahabi is the best achieving
secretary in the last 11 years good
example of of a labour politician
saying good things about a tory
politician uh one of the things about
nadine i met him two weeks ago is uh he
puts psych party politics uh and works
for the common good and he's also quite
interested in fun so good luck with that
okay well uh we'll play that clip to you
tomorrow thanks so much indeed mr mayor
thank you
um are you an adele fan
i am i wasn't last night great and by
the way can i just say this adele
dave little sims wolf alice uh you know
dua lipa
london ruling the world you go down with
the kids it's good to talk to you thanks
a lot i really must let you go otherwise
i'll be in trouble thank you